sigamos resolviendo más problemas de
trigonometría para seguir practicando
estos conceptos permítanme dibujar un
triángulo rectángulo un poco diferente
vamos a dibujarlo así
así
y así digamos que este ángulo de aquí
arriba este ángulo de aquí
es de 0.36 radiales
0.36 radiales
este es un triángulo rectángulo por lo
que este va a ser mi ángulo recto de 90
grados y este lado de aquí mide raíz de
pueden ser centímetros metros las
unidades de longitud que tengamos acá mi
pregunta aquí es cuánto va a valer este
lado de aquí abajo que voy a resaltar de
color verde cuánto va a valer este lado
bueno como resolvimos este tipo de
problemas en la ocasión anterior
tenemos que encontrar con qué tipos de
lados estamos trabajando adyacente
opuesto hipotenusa y luego encontrar la
función trigonométricas que lo relaciona
conocemos que este lado rosa que voy a
resaltar aquí en rosa pues tenemos el
valor raíz de 73 de este lado conozco
cuánto vale este lado y también conozco
el valor de este ángulo de acá y en lo
que queremos encontrar es el lado
opuesto a este ángulo
qué función trigonométricas debemos usar
pues hacemos nuestro armónico zocato
lo voy a poner cada uno en diferente
color
los lados involucrados son el opuesto y
la hipotenusa pues vamos a usar son que
es el opuesto y la hipotenusa
eso nos dice que el seno
del ángulo en este caso es de punto 36
radiales
es igual a lo que mide el cateto opuesto
o lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa
lo que me interesa conocer es el lado
opuesto por lo que lo voy a despejar y
conozco el valor de la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa es raíz de 3 esto es igual al
lado opuesto entre raíz de 73 dije raíz
de tres no raíz cuadrada de 73 voy a
despejar este lado que me interesa el
opuesto lo multiplicó ambos lados de la
igualdad por raíz de 73 me queda que el
lado opuesto es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 73 por el seno
punto 36 radiales
yo no sé cuál es el seno de punto 36
radiales así directamente en mi mente
pero reside que lo podemos consultar en
una tabla o en una calculadora y este
seno de punto 36 radiales esto va a ser
igual
3 x raíz cuadrada de 73
esto como les dije lo podemos consultar
o calcular aunque si lo consultamos o lo
calculamos con la calculadora nos va a
dar un número decimal ahora sustituimos
esto acá tenemos que esto es el seno de
punto 36 radiales ahí esto lo estamos
multiplicando por raíz cuadrada 73 73
73 por raíz cuadrada de 73 me va a dar
73 73 entre 73 va a ser igual a 1 por lo
que nada más me voy a quedar con el 3 mi
lado opuesto va a ser igual a 3 este
lado va a valer 3 unidades y si por
curiosidad ustedes quisieran encontrar
el valor de este otro lado hay dos
formas de hacerlo puede usar el teorema
de pitágoras a cuadrada más de cuadrada
igualase cuadrada o pueden usar
trigonometría vamos a resolverlo de
ambas formas voy a resaltar en azul el
lado que me interesa ahora encontrar
este lado
este lado que buscamos ese lado
adyacente al ángulo y ya conocemos el
lado opuesto y la hipotenusa que
funciona usa en relación a el lado
opuesto y el adyacente pues tenemos el
lado opuesto y el adyacente son con toda
esta es la función que podemos usar la
tangente de punto 36 radiales es igual
al cateto opuesto
entre el cateto adyacente vamos a llamar
a este lado que desconocemos a mayúscula
conozco o puedo encontrar el valor de la
tangente de punto 36 radian es conozco
el lado opuesto pues lo acabo de
encontrar por lo que sustituimos ese
valor acá 3 entre el valor que estoy
buscando que es a podemos usar otra
función trigonométricas para resolver
esto pues si el coseno también nos
involucra el cateto adyacente y la
hipotenusa que conocemos así que el
coseno
de punto 36 radiales es igual al cateto
adyacente que es a nuestra incógnita
entre la hipotenusa que vale raíz
cuadrada de 73
podemos ocupar cualquiera de estas dos
fórmulas si usamos la segunda tendremos
que ha multiplicado ambos lados de la
igualdad por raíz de 73 y va a ser igual
a raíz cuadrada de 73
por el cose no
en punto 36 radiales nuevamente voy a
buscar este valor en una tabla o en la
calculadora y yo les puedo decir que
esto es igual
por raíz cuadrada de 73 entre 73 pueden
confirmar esto último consultando las
tablas de valores de estas funciones
trigonométricas o como les decía usando
su calculadora en modos radiales
esto estaba x raíz cuadrada de 73 raíz
cuadrada de 73 por raíz cuadrada de 73 n
73 dividido en 73 va a ser 1 por lo que
nos va a quedar este valor 8 este lado a
es igual a 8 unidades esto es igual a 8
lo mismo tenemos y usamos la tangente y
solo para mostrarles que todo funciona
con otros conceptos encontraremos este
valor usando el teorema de pitágoras
el teorema de pitágoras
nos dice que la suma de los cuadrados de
los catetos es igual al cuadrado de la
hipotenusa así que el cuadrado de
ángeles 8 al cuadrado más el cuadrado
del otro lado que es 33 al cuadrado debe
ser igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa
la hipotenusa va a la raíz cuadrada de
cuadrada de 73 al cuadrado
esto lo desarrolló 8 x 8 64 + 3 x 39 y
esto debe ser igual a raíz cuadrada de
73 al cuadro que viene siendo 73
y sumamos 64 + 9 efectivamente me da 73
que es igual a 73 y con esto demostramos
que este resultado es correcto creo que
con eso ustedes están listos para
realizar sin problemas ejercicios del
módulo de trigonometría saludos